Ancient wisdom suggests don’t read the comments.
If you do, tread lightly.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews.
Whenever you read about a new study, do you
ever skip to the comment section and find
it filled with especially nasty posts?
Well this could be a real problem for science,
because recent research from the University
of Washington showed that people trust online
comments more than credible sources.
In their study “Reexamining Health Messages
in the Digital Age" the researchers ran two
experiments.
In the first, 129 participants watched made-up
PSAs about vaccines.
One was pro, the other was against.
Afterwards they read fake comments.
The results shocked the researchers.
When the participants filled out questionnaires
on vaccines, people trusted a Joe Schmoe commenter
as much as the PSA.
In the second experience the commenters were
identified as an English literature student,
a lobbyist specializing in healthcare issues
and a medical doctor specializing in infectious
diseases and vaccinology.
Not so surprisingly, the doctor’s comments
outweighed the others in terms of credibility
and their opinions impacted the participants
attitudes MORE than the PSAs.
It’s this phenomena that lead to Popular
Science shutting down its comment section
in September of 2013.
Citing that a “vocal minority of "shrill,
boorish specimens of the lower Internet phyla"
were ruining it for everyone else.”
So why do comment sections get so horrible?
A recent study showed that comment sections
get testy for controversial scientific topics
because of a concept called social identity
theory.
The idea is that we tie our sense of self
worth to membership with a group.
And it’s within our own interest to boost
up our group by sometimes degrading the “opposing”
groups since it reflects back on us.
Think of like sports fans or political parties.
For some scientific topics, there are groups
that hold certain positions.
People are really proud to be affiliated with
these groups.
If a study contradicts the group’s opinion,
people take the science personally.
Like a sports fan talking smack about the
other team, people turn to the comment sections
and hope their buddies back them up.
The researchers say that “Posting a negative
comment appeases a need for affirmation.”
Both of these studies together point to a
larger issue in our culture.
This could be one of the reasons why science
has a publicity problem.
A new Pew study showed scientists and the
public disagree more on topics now than ever.
And that there’s an increase in skepticism
of science in general.
uh oh.
I mean we’re emotional creatures, as much
as we like to think we wouldn’t be persuaded
by
comments, we are.
And as it stands, the comment sections aren’t
the best place for fruitful conversations.
And this is a problem for talking about the
hot button issues of our time.
So how do we communicate science without triggering
a social identity threat?
Please leave some thoughtful comments below
and hit that subscribe button to keep checking
out more DNews everyday of the week